a festive morning in one of the most
densely populated communities in Manila
it began with a motorcade that ended in
a gym
with music clearing gift bags and
children in tears
it was a party to catch up on
vaccinations
we have to convince mothers and the
mothers have to convince their children
so we really have to make it enjoyable
and you know I lay fears of our parents
mistrust of vaccines particularly for
children peaked in 2017 after a backlash
against the Dengue jab denvaksha French
manufacturer sanofi said it was
potentially harmful for those who've
never had Dengue fever but at that point
the Philippine government had already
administered at least one dose to more
than 800 000 school children we got
scared at the time because we were
hearing children getting sick from
dengvaxia
scare led to a measles outbreak in 2019
and now Health experts dread a repeat
at least 67 million children around the
world missed out on routine vaccinations
between 2019 and 2021 that's according
to UNICEF now here in the Philippines a
million children did not receive a
single dose in 2021 one of the main
reasons the covid-19 pandemic
Philippines pandemic lockdowns were some
of the most restrictive and longest in
the world
just like immunization are neglected and
aside from that there were also the
lockdowns the restrictions so parents
caregivers they're afraid to bring their
children to the health centers because
they're afraid of you know Contracting
the covid-19 themselves the UNICEF says
awareness events like this are necessary
as governments play catch-up
they will have to move quick as they're
up against viruses that spread rapidly
find it below Al Jazeera Manila